well it is worth kind of looking into to
some of
the numbers in particular uh that scary
chart
um which sir patrick valence showed us
which looks more or less like this we've
recreated it here
and this shows you essentially uh the
number of cases that we've seen in
recent days so that's the these black
bars here
and what you've got in the white bars is
the illustration
uh that the chief scientific advisor was
talking about so cases doubling every
seven days and what it gives you
an idea of is what happens if a disease
spreads unchecked and that is indeed
you know our experience from the
previous time there was the lockdown
um he said the previous time i should
say the disease was spreading this this
fast
uh 3105 new cases on the 15th of
september
he said it could rise to approximately
49 000 new cases that's daily new cases
on october 13th if it doubles uh every
seven days but
it is just worth asking there are some
question marks and some assumptions that
go into these kinds of
illustrations that are worth uh question
i've just kind of converted that into a
line graph so you can compare it with
some other things because
for instance we know that last time
around when the disease was spreading
for instance it was spreading at a far
faster rate at least on the basis of the
death numbers we had at the time
uh doubling every kind of three or four
days and that actually would create an
even bigger even steeper line than sir
patrick violence was talking about
but it is just worth it asking why is he
talking about it doubling every
seven days now i asked that question
just because that equates to about 10
percent
growth but we know from the government's
own estimates remember they did the r
number they updated it
on friday we know from their estimates
uh last time around on friday they said
it was growing at a rate from
two to seven percent so that's still
quite a lot shy of of ten percent have
things changed since we don't really
know we didn't get much
elaboration from from either uh of the
speakers
today but nonetheless there's a big
difference between that seven percent
growth and the ten percent growth uh
that sir patrick balance was talking
about and i'll show you what what we
mean here so
that's the patrick balance and what he
was talking about doubling every seven
days now if it's doubling
uh every ten days so it's confusingly
that's seven percent growth
it's actually a lot shallow a lot more
shallow uh that line
it's still growing quite fast in europe
to kind of towards twenty thousand
uh by the middle of october but that's
you know less than half of the forty
nine thousand
that he was talking about but that's not
the only thing to bear in mind the
current growth rate there's also the
question of
whether that growth rate is actually
going to continue and the reason to kind
of focus on that is that as both of the
uh two scientists in the chief medical
office were talking about uh today
we are following a relatively similar
trajectory in this disease in this
latest wave
as france and indeed spain so you can
see their number of cases going up and
up and up there
where's the uk we're more or less in
line that's the latest figures that
we've had
as of yesterday more or less following
in line so the big question is
what would happen if we followed either
of those lines more or less would it be
the same
as what separate balance was talking
about in other words up like this
or would it look different and actually
if we were to follow in this country as
indeed
was quite similar last time iron as was
the case last time around with italy in
france
if we were to follow more or less in
line with where their case trajectory is
it would be a very different picture it
would be a far more shallow increase
there we are
is what would happen if we were in line
with france if they were in line with
spain it would be more or less the same
you'd be up to about 10 000 cases
by the middle of october rather than 40
000 cases
and so while clearly these are just
illustrations and the chief scientific
advisor was clear about that there was a
big difference between
what some other people would think is a
more plausible situation in other words
that we're going to just follow
in line with where france is going where
spain is going uh
compared with this very scary line that
we saw earlier on today